foreign
welcome to my talk which is called
technology is not neutral a short guide
to technology ethics which is also the
title of my book which was published in
February and I believe is available here
at the Bookshop in case anyone is
interested in seeing more so
I will get into
um the sort of meaty argument of the
book but I wrote it because I have
worked in technology for over 20 years
and this kind of book did not exist when
I started out and I deeply wish that it
had been because I have both witnessed
many horrific things and been part of
things that in retrospect were not great
it definitely could have been better so
when I wanted to do now that I'm in my
mid-40s was package up my learnings and
also all of the research that I've done
because I'm now a professional
researcher and pass it on to the next
Generation but also to the public so I
presented this book at the artificial
intelligence all party parliamentary
group in Parliament on the 4th of July
which as an American was a little bit of
a winky joke
um I've taken it I'm taking it rather to
Scotland where we'll be talking about it
at data Fest and hopefully to the
devolved government there and to Wales
it's very much a book that's to help not
just technologists but journalists
parents teachers lawmakers regulators
everyone who might have a dog in this
fight it's a quote
former president Harry S Truman
so it's accessible you don't have to be
a technologist there is no code in it
there are no scary computer architecture
Graphics it's really more about how
humans use technology and why that's
such a problematic concept and has been
pretty much since we invented our first
tools so without further ado
we're going to give a little overview
and if we have time we'll go through a
really powerful example because Britain
is a world leader for all the wrong
reasons in biometric and surveillance
Technologies and it's what I really went
deep on in the book to give a case study
because when we normally think of
surveillance technology as a dystopian
argument we point to China and I was
like why point to China when we can just
look right here at home
so you can see the tone of where this
chat will go
very very quickly I just wanted to kind
of introduce myself so I've worked in
the private sector mainly but I also
have had training and a career as a
researcher largely in political risk and
technology and over the years the two of
those things have merged technology has
become increasingly political in terms
of the public eye
uh and vice versa so American by birth
uh French later on there's a lot of
French stuff in the book and obviously
it's a philosophy book so the
Anglo-Saxon world doesn't really train
its young people in philosophy but the
French do so if you're a French student
you're going to be doing eight hours of
philosophy every week in high school my
American upbringing I had zero so it's
quite hard to talk about technology
ethics if you have no training in
philosophy which I have a conspiracy
theory about it if you keep people
ignorant on philosophy then they can't
really be the critical thinkers that
perhaps that we need them to be and then
I came to the UK in 1998 became a
citizen in 2000 and thus wanted to write
a book that really showcased the United
Kingdom because again so many Tech
discussions are either about the United
States and Silicon Valley or about China
but in fact so much that's important
about tech is happening here in Europe
so it's a little bit different the
reason I'm over there with the BBC Mike
is that I often do radio and the world
service so if you're ever up between one
and two in the morning God help you if
you are but you might hear my dull sit
tones talking about politics and Tech so
that's enough of that and this is the
book obviously
a little cheeky reference actually I
should say so we debated a lot the cover
there I wanted to have a technology that
would be recognizable anywhere in the
world so we picked the smartphone such a
powerful one I was super nervous about
putting Satan on the cover largely
because that was not my dream as a first
time writer to put a book out with that
I was also coming from the states as you
know we like to ban books a lot people
get very serious about their religion
there
um I just made me a bit nervous on the
back cover it's the same image but it's
an angel
to be fair to play with the technology
is not neutral so I didn't want to
demonize any Tech workers here who feel
like God damn I'm trying to save the
world and you make me out to be Satan I
know I feel your pain and you're an
angel in the back cover
so what is it
we have Ada Lovelace lady Lovelace you
may recognize here on the left and we
have Socrates here on the right and I
just wanted to sort of give ourselves a
bit of a visual reference for those who
are more visual thinkers Ada Lovelace is
thought of as the world's first computer
programmer she worked with Charles
Babbage he had her look over one of his
manuscripts she actually re-translated
it it had been translated into Italian
he asked her to translate it back into
English and then she added something
like 19 000 notes of like extra thoughts
and her extra thoughts were of course
brilliant but they were both kind of
ahead of their time and their writings
and inventions kind of fell into a bit
of
obsolescence really a bit hidden until
Alan Turing came along read her notes
and was like this is brilliant and of
course he's the founder or one of the
founders of artificial intelligence so
we trace the origins of computer
programming back to her again another
really nice reason to talk about the
UK's role in technology and of course I
wanted to put Socrates on but I've
presented this to a few places and I
take the point this is very
western-centric and of course technology
is global and philosophy is global every
culture on Earth has had Philosophy for
thousands of years and we could put
someone besides
an old white man like Socrates if we
wanted we could have Confucius we could
have Buddha we could talk about any
number of people who could hold the
philosophy space so I just wanted to
acknowledge that critique early on
the problem statement because like all
good technologists you have to decide
when you're going to build something
what is the problem we're trying to
solve what options we have for solving
it how will we know if we've solved it
or not how do we define success what are
the metrics to measure that and then do
we want to be able to do any
benchmarking because potentially other
people are trying to solve it too so how
do we know whose solution is the most
beneficial
or the least harmful
or vice versa so the problem statement I
I sort of came up with and had on my
wall for the four years I was writing
this was how we can create and use
technology so that they deliver maximum
benefit and minimum harm and again a
note to people who know their British
philosophy that's from utilitarianism
which originates here in this country so
there's a lot I've realized as an
immigrant that the British way of
thinking has infused my American mind
it's a lot a lot of British thinking in
this book
very practical so this is a scary slide
this is just for people who like to look
at slide decks later I'm really happy to
share this if anyone wants it I will
very happily email it out and I just put
it in because again I give this to lots
of people who have never studied
philosophy in their life just to tell
them where are you on the map of the
Mind philosophy has six branches largely
we could make this far more complicated
but this is like your minimum viable
philosophy slide okay philosophy ethics
is where we are with technology ethics
but you can have a much more powerful
discussion if you're at least aware of
the other five branches so this is not
something to get scary about or be like
oh my God she's going to talk to us
about the small print I'm not it's just
there for people who like to read or
want to know more but it's just kind of
like the questions
you know how should people act what do
people think is rights how do we take
moral knowledge and put it into practice
and operationalize it
what does right even mean and that can
sound really abstract but I was recently
talking with deepmind also a British
company based here in London artificial
intelligence world leader which was
recently acquired by Google a few years
ago for I think around 400 million
dollars not too shabby they have an
operational ethics team
so this is not just something for white
papers or books or discussion groups
there are companies out there who are
looking at ethics and Technology ethics
and building it into their business
practices so it's just to be aware of
that if this is like boring ignore that
slide but for some people they like it
so
that's great what the hell does any of
this have to do with technology for
those of you like hardcore coders or
designers in the room might be like this
is a lot for 10 am and I am with you
so the first concept to understand is
technology ethics is happening all
around you so even if you are not tuned
into this or if you don't think it's
important or you don't care
may I rest your mind at ease that there
are many people who are working on this
and you are living in their world you
may not know that but hopefully this
will show you a little bit
if you choose to ignore it or to not
take a stand on it that's fine but
that's actually still a position
it's kind of one of those things that
once you become aware of it you can't
unsee it my goal with this talk is not
to get you to agree with me or disagree
with me on anything it's simply to
hopefully raise some awareness and get
you thinking about it a bit in an
interesting way for you as a citizen and
as a consumer my argument is that
there's no such thing as being neutral
on technology ethics that is a very
controversial position we will
acknowledge the other side of that
debate there are lots of very
intelligent people who totally think I'm
wrong and think technology is neutral
some of them may be in this room so
we'll take a look and see why
because I trained as a historian of
France and France is a really big part
of my sort of intellectual laboratory I
felt it was important to have an
obligatory quote from a French
philosopher and I indeed had this on my
wall I was writing because I loved it
um it just keeps things in mind when
you're coming up with solutions that
when you invent the ship you create the
Shipwreck the plane the plane crash
electricity electrocution it's just a
really nice simple way reminding you
that anytime you're putting something
into the world
there will be like a negative space or
or just the potentiality for that and
just to be aware of it
every technology carries with it its own
negativity that's invented at the same
time as technical progress that is like
very humbling I feel like if every
technologist would have had that and was
brushing their teeth every morning while
they looked at that you might go about
your day a bit differently
and it's hard because you're under so
much pressure a lot of the time or
you're working with clients who have
budgets in a very specific Mo goal of
what they want to do you don't always
have time to to make ethics part of your
process I hope that this will help
people think about one that's worthwhile
but first experts who think that
technology is neutral and again this is
a very powerful view lots of people
particularly in the United States and in
Silicon Valley like to have it and I
think it's because in my country
when we talk about things like
responsibility we instantly think about
liability and then we think about who we
can sue right so Americans have like a
very specific conception of holding
people in power to account right it's
like take them to court it's like I'm
probably one of our biggest phrases and
I don't know if that's necessarily true
for the rest of the world so we're a
litigious people so this this argument
exists in that context if you can say
that technology is neutral then you're
not responsible for what happens with it
right it's the whole guns don't kill
people people kill people argument
which of course is very interesting
because I can kill a lot more people
with an ak-15 than I can a revolver or a
shotgun so like even the example of the
technology there
is not neutral a gun is not a gun it's
not a gun they're different and certain
people have training to use those things
and certain people don't or have access
to them or not so like instantly you can
complicate even something like guns
don't kill people people kill people
this matters because now we're talking
about things like artificial
intelligence and weapons that can kill
without a human being involved
so if you're going to build that system
and places like mod in this country will
be looking at that DOD in the United
States you want to have that discussion
of if it isn't guns don't kill people
people kill people What happens when you
take a human out of the loop
who's responsible then
the person who codes it
the person who builds it the investors
who fund it what if that's your pension
fund that's investing in that
are you responsible for it right so it
gets rough it's super messy by the way
like don't leave this talk thinking that
you're going to have any easy answers
you'll just have a migraine I have
earned these forehead wrinkles
so moving on to the people who think it
is neutral
so Gary castrov I'm sure known to many
people here chess Grandmaster wrote a
book called Deep thinking which I really
recommend reading if only for the
amazing fact that he wrote an entire
book about Ai and only mentions women
twice one of whom is his mother
so that was that was a painful 200
something Pages for me Tech is agnostic
it amplifies us ethical AI is like
ethical electricity so he tweeted that I
follow him on Twitter I really admire
him and I was like okay I'm I'm with him
so your experience of plugging in your
phone and using some electricity to
charge up your phone should hopefully be
the same as yours as long as everybody's
routers are the same and nobody's like
blowing up their phone if you take your
phone and try and do it in Italy you
might have a problem because their
electricity is different but in theory
electricity should be the same for
everyone in this room
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas